lyautey squeeze aujourd'hui se trouve
enfin sur elliott soleil chaud d'un jeu
que j'attends depuis des mois et des
mois depuis qu'il a été annoncé
aujourd'hui on a les mains dessus
et croyez moi on va se faire plaisir à
jouer au jeu je vais essayer de vous
faire suivre l'histoire un peu faire un
montage mais pas trop violent avec pas
trop trop de coupures vont se font au
moment où il se passe vraiment rien
comme ça vous allez comprendre
l'histoire je vais la comprendre aussi
et on va à flipper tout ensemble ces
partis dernier rapport du véhicule
commercial nostromo troisième officier
au rapport
les autres membres de l'équipage kane
lambert darker prête
h oui gallas son bar oh ça fait du monde
ça fait du monde y en ait lieu pas très
gentil coup elle peut pas faire des
câlins cargaison et l'appareil détruit
avec de la chance le réseau devrait me
repérer ici ripley dernier survivant des
instruments ok je sais pas si vous avez
vu un des quatre et l'yonne qui existait
en film à la base eliot
en tout cas moi j'ai vu le 1 c'est
vraiment et ça date de trente ans et
c'est vraiment bas c'est ce à quoi voit
là d'un bon jeu gbagbo mais voilà on se
bat par quels moyens il ya des liens qui
se retrouvent dans le vaisseau et à sa
part carrément steak est donc là je
pense qu'on va revivre un peu ça c'est
parti mon nom est samuel salut cng pour
la compagnie très bien au sujet de votre
mère s'emballer steak
on pense peut-être l'avoir enfin
retrouver un mandat à san jose c'est un
vaisseau de commerce appelé l'année si
doha qui a récupéré ce qui semble être
la boîte noire qui enregistre et la fin
du nostromo
sa hausse à jackson s'est articulé et ça
disait quoi nous lignon nous l'ignorons
très bien justement a été envoyée à la
station sébastopol sébastopol est un
dépôt de ravitaillement dans la région
c'est c'est une plateforme de transfert
et déjà arrangé
il y à un vaisseau coursier le torrent
qui croisera notre route dans deux jours
ne notre voyage vers la station 4 mois
et un autre employé
et vous si vous le souhaitez j'ai
compris pourquoi vous avez choisi de
travailler dans la zone où elle a
disparu
c'est bien vous la cherchez encore
n'est-ce pas j'ai obtenu le feu vert
pour vous offrir une place pour ce
voyage sur le torrent
ça ne dépend que de vous aken auquel
elle est partie recherche de sa maman
surallocation ça manque était papa piégé
dans le vaisseau avec les lionnes
oui je me crois vacances voilà ça
commence bien esseulé bay
enfin on se réveille du coup ah oui
dorment dans des trucs voilà ça me plaît
ça me plaît hopla please sinin s'il vous
plaît enregistrez vous appuyez sur les
touches déplacement pour marcher on y
est on est dans le vaisseau hockey même
si un jour on va se retrouver en galère
mais bon alors il faut que je
m'enregistre je peux pas vous faire une
vidéo de plus de 10 minutes aujourd'hui
parce que je n'ai pas encore sorti donc
au alors ça fait quoi ça welcome à
rouler yes
explorez le torrent le torrent le
torrent ont bon roi le vaisseau la
petite musique qui fait bien qui me fait
plaisir
alors qu'est ce qu'on n'a pas réussi
habillez-vous alors carrément à poil il
est temps de s'habiller quand même c'est
le casier de samuel ont volé les
affaires de siemens à hasnon non moi je
juge fabi hier à une douche ya pas
besoin on bat les steaks de plus et
finalement ah bah voilà ces billets
c'est ça qu'on veut
parce que habillé face à un alien tu te
défoncer mais nul face à un alien c'est
vraiment horrible
ok on habille et maintenant sauver la
partie oh c'est pas des sauvegardes
automatiques faut sauvegarder des trucs
comme ça
ok d'accord oh mon dieu attend plus ça
met du temps à quoi s'était poursuivie
par le par les lionnes et que tu fais en
bref ça sent pas bon voilà ouah ça nous
fait vraiment dans l'ambiance est
géniale regardez comme c'est 3 et fin
[ __ ] all away
tu es ma première amis bonjour rien de
bon dans cette journée et je pense pas
qu'il fasse jour non plus céder des
magasins sur le lien sur un centre mal
tu te sens mal la perte du nostromo et
de sa cargaison ont coûté beaucoup
d'argent à l'entreprise oui c'est
important qu'on découvre ce qui s'est
passé ces salles on est là pour
découvrir ce qui s'est passé sur le dos
trop beau je me rends compte que ta mère
est porté disparu depuis 15 ans oui que
toi tu bats que moi je la cherche c'est
pas grave on y trouvera chacune notre
compte exactement à les revoir
bonne soirée et a vu sa maison mais
tais-toi [ __ ] j'en ai marre d'elle là
elle me raconte sa vie je suis pas tombé
c'est ok c'est à des problèmes aux os
les effets de fumée c'est magnifique
donc l'hôte a été un peu on est en train
de déprimer
comment vous faites pour supporter un
hyper sommeil il faut il faut que
j'arrive à faire ça comme ça mais super
seront fiers de moi au samuel ce matin
tatinghem assassinat sa mère est déjà
debout bien je n'ai pas autant besoin de
sommeil que vous tous
l'hyper sommeil ne lui a sans doute pas
fini bah oui à l'animal devait la
rejoindre au revoir sa mauvaise et merci
pour tes recherches sur les vaisseaux
ben faut que je retourne en maintenant
mais je ne veux pas parler cette femme
dépressive me revoici femmes samuel m'a
demandé de te parler alors vu samuel oui
j'ai vu ça doit faire des soeurs qui il
dit oui
parlez à taylor et pourquoi ils viennent
pas moi ces gens pouvaient c'est moi qui
dois aller chercher comme ça on est
arrivé ok tout le monde doit les sur le
pont alors on va faire un point sur le
pont salut aulas samuel lui lui je le
sens pas du tout je les avais tous et
bon voyage
oui je vais prévenir sébastopol et
arrangé débarquement avec lui d'accord
c'est parti ces partis ont fait observer
la proche sur les écrans ou sur les
écrans je veux des écrans je veux voir
soit sur tweets sur twitter la route
iphone du débarquement à bavois la
hausse est beau bon moi j'ai mis un
paysage mais il faut que je ramasse mon
briefing il est là je crois que ramasser
le briefing
on débarque est-ce qu'on pourrait voir
passe aux écrans de compte mes fesses si
nous y sommes
voici la station sevastopol oui
waouh il ya des dégâts dirait bien que
oui en effet à hawaï lambiotte ali
détenez la boîte noire du vaisseau
nostromo nous demandons l'autorisation
pour transfert immédiat de nos passagers
à bâbord à vous la personne oui c'est
capte mal mon gars ou la cigale
opérateurs là puisqu'elle change et vite
ah oui on comprend rien on fait rien du
tout comprends que dalle
les communications de la station les
rosiers ok donc on doit aller voir
qu'est ce qui se passe dedans c'est ça
c'est là que ça sent pas bon
maintenir le torrent en position que
pendant 24 heures vous aurez déjà
contacté ouais bon voyage ok qui elle
peut rester là que pendant 24 heures
donc il faut qu'on soit revenu avant 24
heures c'est là qu'on y va on embarque
au nom et j'espère qu'il va lui arriver
à cette poule dépressif
ça m'embêterait
[Musique]
derrière moi c'est non
elle a peur noah les courageuses par
contre waouh ça doit être tellement
impressionnant faire un truc pareil
je ne sais pas qui tu t'entends bien
c'est quoi ce délire
non pas la dépressive
oh
[Musique]
mais non mais j'ai besoin de voir des
mecs de gravity ça me halidou et sur
vous on sait pas où ils sont j'ai parlé
j'ai devant les chercher c'est ça c'est
exactement ça donc je crois mais c'est
carrément catastrophique en train de se
passer
on est bien qu'à au yen à l'air dans le
vaisseau apparemment des flammes et de
la fumée
même temps le vaisseau il pas en bon
état il a un peu pété de partout
objectif trouver de l'aide mais je veux
bien en trouver de l'aide mais j'espère
que j'ai pas la trouver auprès de la
lionne l'aide hop là on retient la
combinaison à ascom plus correct et là
je peux le jeu pourrait la remettre non
je piégé dans le vaisseau maintenant
nickel alors on s'en va waouh cher on ne
sait pas ce qu'il ya dans ce foutu
vaisseau utiliser les bornes
d'enregistrement pour sauvegarder votre
progression vous serez avertis c'est des
ennemis sont proches c'est mona
sauvegarde et on est tranquille [ __ ]
alors on peut aller qu'à droite
tiens à mon avis au maire olala ça sent
pas bon et c'est magnifique
sans déconner alors est-ce que je peux
aller par là whaou pour ce cadre s'il
vous plaît dans les flammes savalas les
briquets bic dans 2000 ans ils sont
comme ça finalement ce sera des
chalumeaux quoi alors omis que vois-je
mais oui c'est comme dans le film que
ces fameux conduit c'est parti je
suppose qu'on va passer de côté du feu
comme ça on est mal en point messieurs
dames
on est très mal en point oh la la la la
aulas mais c'est ambiance mais bon dieu
aulas y at il quelqu'un dans ces
conduits avec moi pour m'aider s'il vous
plaît voilà effectivement on est passé
de l'autre côté du feu oh là là là là
non mais il ya tout qui bouge tout qui 3
mais ça va pas du tout par où je vais
[ __ ] je veux pas aller par là je peux
aller que à gauche ou droit tout droit
c'est un peu risqué mais bon on va le
tenter
on écrit au maire d' j'ai mis son
mégaphone dans mon casque pour qu'il
fait mais je regrette quoi mais on est
tombé superbe à merde j'aurais dû à la
gauche
ok on se relève qu'est-ce qu'on question
fait là y'a pas un petit un petit samuel
ou une petite dépressif dans le coin
tout nous pu me gêne
pourquoi pourquoi j'ai ramassé un
fumigène c'est pas mal mais ça me
servira quoi assez pour éclairer je
suppose un ouais voilà c'est un plein
nickel et ben c'est très beau ou la hâte
en avons fait qu'il pète à la gueule ce
serait une mort un peu bête comme
awesome you always nos où il ya des
écritures la bassée médias glauque à les
cours quand on passe dans un deuxième
truc comme ça et maintenant qu'est-ce
qu'il ya
huawei a dit oui déjà ça commence bien
le bruit en masse et là aussi le bordel
je peux passer par là j'ai peut-être
raté un truc là à ça à mon avis je peux
je peux faire un truc c'est une sorte
d'ascenseur ou qu'est ce que c'est c'est
parti on grave on grimpe vers la lumière
mais on ne sait pas ce qui va se passer
et voilà j'en suis désolé mais je peux
pas vous en montrer plus parce qu'après
je vais dépasser la limite des 10
minutes qu'on m'a imposé je vous propose
c'est que je fais une deuxième vidéo sur
le jeu au tout de suite demain soir
comme ça vous serez au courant
rapidement de la suite des événements je
suis vraiment content de ne font pas ce
petit let's play sur l isolation
j'attendais vraiment j'espère que ça va
vous plaire j'espère que ça va me plaire
et puis on se retrouve pour la suite
demain soir justement pis
[Musique]